palä wieder müssen Juden Angst haben bei
den poalästinensischen Protesten in
Deutschland entlätt sich auch
Antisemitismus Judenhass ist wieder eine
Realität und er nimmt
[Musik]
zu Judenhass hat mit Juden nichts zu tun
es hat mit Hass zu tun
egal was die Juden machen können getauft
sein integriert sein für die kaiserkämpf
völlig integriert Steuerzahler sein sie
sind noch immer
gehasst ein Wort wie Pogrom oder
Antisemitismus kam mir früher vor wie
ein Zitat vielleicht von irgendeiner
Website weil ich nie persönlich von
Antisemitismus betroffen
[Musik]
war nach dem 7 Oktober jedoch kommt es
immer näher es wird immer größer und ist
nun auch für mich zu einer schrecklichen
Realität
geworden
Berlin vergangenes Wochenende ein
Auftritt der jüdischen Band volkadu
anlass ist eine
Buchvorstellung die Musikerin jel gart
war gerade noch im Sinai musizierte dort
vor ägyptischem und israelischem
Publikum gemeinsam mit beduinischen
Musikern einen Tag vor der Terrorattacke
der Hamas vom 710 reiste sie zurück nach
Deutschland an diesem Abend steht sie
mit dem Rabbiner Walter Rotschild und
dem Schriftsteller Krampitz auf der
Bühne der Anlass Krampitz hat ein Buch
über Antisemitismus in der Weimarer
Republik geschrieben ein Buch in dem es
auch um die lange Tradition des
Judenhasses geht es kann jederzeit
passieren es sind ganz
normale Menschen nicht
Nazis die einfach nur
in in in schwere soziale Bedrängnis
geraten
sind ja aber diese Leute lassen sich
dann dirigieren lassen sich
manipulieren judenh wird bei uns mit der
Pogromnacht 1938 und mit der Schoa in
Verbindung gebracht nur wenige Menschen
wissen dass bereits am 5 und 6 November
1923 auf dem Höhepunkt der Inflation in
Berlin ein Pogrom stattgefunden hat
damals wurde Bargeld nicht gezählt
sondern gewogen es war einfach nichts
wert
das Scheunenviertel Schauplatz des
prgroms war damals ein Gebiet armer
Leute viele Migranten vor allem auch
Flüchtlinge aus Osteuropa bestimmten das
Straßenbild wir begleiten Karsten
Krampitz in Berlin auf seiner
Spurensuche nach diesem vergessenen
Pogrom er führt Studenten durch das
Viertel für die rosa
luxemburgstiftung als ich das Buch
geschrieben habe habe ich
noch gedacht als Historiker das
progromeme gegen Juden gehören der der
Vergangenheit an sind Geschichte aber es
ist ja nicht der Fall das haben wir
erlebt am am 7 Oktober da ist nichts
nichts vorbei es finden sich nur noch
wenige Spuren aus damaliger Zeit obwohl
das Scheunenviertel einst als Zentrum
jüdischen Lebens in Berlin
galt und jetzt hab ein bisschen
scheuenviertel also das scheuenviertel
war das womöglich dicht besiedeltste
Quartier in in Berlin in jedem Haus
haben jüdische Menschen gelebt das war
total irre das gab Kos Bäckereien
fleischerledden ja also schon in der
Zeit vor dem ersten Weltkrieg ist hier
das jüdische Leben praktisch
ablüt unweit des Scheunenviertels am
Arbeitsamt in der Alexanderstraße
sammelte sich vor 100 Jahren eine
aufgebrachte Mute das Arbeitsamt konnte
kein Notgeld auszahlen aufgewiegelt von
völkischen Kräften richtet sich der Zorn
der Arbeitslosen gegen die
[Musik]
Juden man geht von aus dass irgendwer
gesagt hat es gibt kein Notgeld also
kein wertbeständiges Geld die Juden hab
die sind aufgehetzt worden die Leute
sind in Panik und dann muss das
am Abend zwischen 6 und 7 Uhr ist ein
großer Haufen Menschen vor meiner
Wohnung erschienen sie schlugen Türen
und Fenster ein und raubten sämtliche
Waren mein Eindruck war dass es sich um
einen vollständig organisierten Überfall
handelte ein Mann der anscheinend der
Anführer war leitete die Plünderer
Krampitz publiziert in seinem Buch
erstmal solche Ausschnitte jüdisch
opferprotokolle aus der Zeit auffällig
dieurütung der
stundenlang wütete ungebremst der
Mob dem Gastwirt in der grenadierstraße
14 Halm korngut wurden nicht nur
sämtliche Waren sondern auch 2 Billionen
Mark gestohlen die Tageseinnahmen
korngut klagt Polizeibeamte waren
zugegen haben die Plünderung aber nicht
verhindert auf offener Straße wurden
Juden verprügelt ausgeraubt und
entkleidet ist alles sehr traurig das
hat sich an zwei Tagen
ähm abgespielt vor allem im am 5
November so um die Mittagsstunde herum
muss es ganz schreckliche Wesen sein und
dann eben ist mindestens die zweite
Welle war dann
organisiert viele der Juden waren zuvor
bereits aus Angst vor Progromen aus
Russland geflohen sie hofften auf Schutz
in Berlin doch im Scheunenviertel holte
sie die Gewalt wieder
ein
viel zu spät schritt die Polizei ein
verhaftet wurden die Juden die sich
gegen die wütenden deutschen zur weh
setzten von ihnen viele Mitglieder des
reichsbunds jüdischer Frontsoldaten
jüdische Veteranen aus dem ersten
Weltkrieg die Polizei nahm sie in
Gewahrsam misshandelte
viele ich bin zwar Historiker ich finde
es interessant dass man schreibt Büch
über die Geschichte ich finde es wichtig
dass Leute lernen Geschichte aber mein
Problem ist nicht ob es eine
Straßenschild gibt mit Information mein
Problem ist darf ich auf diese Straße
laufen ohne
Angst es gibt wieder die Angst Opfer zu
werden doch davon möchte sich jelgard
nicht leiten
[Musik]
lassen
jüdische Kultur findet immer den Weg von
der Tragödie zurück zum Optimismus wir
versuchen trotz der disaster einer guten
Zukunft entgegenzusehen stärker zu
werden
gemeinsam für mich ist es wichtig dieses
kulturelle Verständnis der jüdischen
Menschen im Konzert auszudrücken oft
beginnt es traurig aber dann siehst Du
plötzlich das
Licht
nie wieder ist jetzt Karsten krampits
Buch kommt zur richtigen
[Musik]
Zeit